so many owning a home is a dream for so
many it's a dream
increasingly distant dan and his fiance
are first-time buyers they've postponed
their wedding and saved a 10
deposit but it's no longer enough
mortgage lenders now want as much as 20
we're looking at a smallish two bed flat
in um sort of on the outskirts of
of london and we're talking sort of we
need seventy thousand pounds for a
deposit now
um which is enormous amount of money um
you know
double the amount we were initially
looking at we tried to do the online
agreement mortgage agreement in
principle and with about three or four
different lenders
and each time it said declined rejected
big red cross
we may be in recession but it's not
affected house prices here in nottingham
they're up nearly five percent on last
year
the largest jump of any uk city it looks
like we've got an amazing garden
richard's been selling homes here for
decades and says the market's busy
we're seeing more money from london and
the home counties
than i've seen in over 20 years coming
into the city
looking for those yields looking for
those investments bad news for
first-time buyers
because you know those properties are
the great ones to buy
to rent out there are two concurrent
forces squeezing the less well off
firstly a credit crunch banks just
aren't lending as readily
to those with small deposits and
secondly prices are actually
rising they're being pushed up by
wealthy buyers active in the market
buoyed on by a cut in stamp duty and
pent-up demand
it all means increased inequality in a
market already inaccessible to so many
the data shows how the availability of
loans for those with smaller deposits
has plummeted
in recent months and the impact's
beginning to show
demand from first-time buyers is waning
many likely priced out
and it's being noted the prime minister
this week promised the return of five
percent deposits for first-time buyers
we will help turn generation rent
into generation buy saeed says that's
urgent a first-time buyer himself but
also one of the government's social
mobility commissioners
the way things are at the minute the
market is really going to widen
inequality across the uk and harm
social mobility if they are pushed out
now it's very unlikely that they will
ever own their own property because they
will be forced into this rental
cycle where often rents are double what
your mortgage would be
many experts believe a downturn may be
coming
fixing this long unequal market will be
a long road
helen and smith sky news